[Музика]
дан бойл і мило
раніше
був залежний від вашого тіла сьогодні ввечері
на вечірку
але давайте вогню в небі в зброї
Я хочу літати
мені
і я хочу
відчуй ритм мого серцебиття
мені
відчуйте те саме серцебиття, яке танцює
ми йдемо
[Музика]
в музиці
вчора між твоєю музикою
[Музика]
і я хочу
з гарячим ритмом
любов
[Музика]
і в травні
і ми можемо
[Музика]
у суперрозтяжці це буде контакт 9
ти відпустиш свої різні стегна, це я
ви потрапили в це життя, щоб насолоджуватися цим
божевільна ніч, я хочу доторкнутися до твоєї талії
і твої губи я хочу поцілувати, ти хочеш бути
[Музика]
моя мама
від мого серця
мені те, що я хочу
ритм музичного танцю
ліки
був
[Музика]
підвищити температуру
з гарячим хлопцем
твоя свічка
я хочу поговорити
[Музика]
музика
з гарячим ритмом
[Музика]
чекати
о
людей, з якими страждає терпляча любов
підвищити температуру вогню я хочу
танцювати
[Музика]
я хочу танцювати
супер кантабрійський
але не
Андрус і сумний
Вибачте
[Музика]